[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport report dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast frau starb
wachtmeister silvia steiner herzlich
willkommen liebe silvia du bist
sportschützen und du bist auch schon für
tokio qualifiziert herzliche gratulation
dazu aber fangen wir ganz am anfang an
wie wird man denn als frau in österreich
sportschützen ja dialog mit zehn jahren
wenn papa auf dem schießstand und
seitdem bin ich mit einer unterbrechung
beim schießen blieb das heißt das
schießen war schon in der familie
präsent wieder das war der vater selbst
leistungsspitze oder einfach in der
freizeit am schießstand gewesen ihr eure
papa war schon bei weiß gar nicht wie
viel freiraum geholt ich glaub 80er
jahre war und die wahlleistung schütze
also bis zu europameisterschaften und so
ist dies für uns war dies ganz normal
mit schüssen zum damit rufen zum daher
und ja irgendwann bin ich noch einmal
mit gong und das war's was hat sich da
fasziniert als junges mädchen beim
schießstand zu stehen und mitmachen zu
können also was was war da der reiz ist
war noch unklar ist leichter und noch
mit ich glaub ja im ersten jahr bei der
bezirksmeisterschaft mit disco dabei
bleiben kann man da auch ein talent
erkennen also gibt es das wie in anderen
sportarten dass wenn ein schwimmer oder
eine schwimmerin ins wasser springt dass
man sagt die die oder der die sind
talentiert die die werden was gibt's das
beim schießen auch hat der herr papa dir
dann sofort talent auch entdeckt oder
geht das gar nicht beim schießen wo es
gibt schon viele gesagt gehöre talent
ich habe nicht so richtig führt dafür
doch und war wirklich einmal recht
erfolgreich und es ging nach dem motto
musik konzentrieren korsika schon okay
was kurs über längere zeit konzentrieren
ist im handling gut ist in der
feinmotorik gut und das glaube ich schon
dass man diese erkennen
dass diese hüft und lag das bei dir er
dann im naturell in im charakter dass du
diese eigenschaften hat ist oder weil du
eben den sport schon von klein auf
daheim mit beobachten konntest und
gesehen dass da das sind die dinge die
da wichtig sind also warum ich warum ich
das frage ist also einfach um zu sehen
wo ist wo ist denn die gewichtung mehr
also kommt das von vom inneren oder kann
man das dann von außen auch wirklich
einfach an lernen weil man es permanent
beobachtet also mögliche sicher beides
also bei mir ist vom charakter her bin
eher ruhig eher introvertiert und jetzt
unsere sternisko aufregung also dagegen
darunter sterben einfach durch eine
frühe linie und man sieht bei uns vor
bewegung aus die dass sie die hoffnung
auf dem blog bewegt im inneren chance
natürlich ob man zu 100 stars und es
gibt da war welche robbie show erlebt
junge kinder junge burma was die einfach
kaum fünf minuten ruhig sein können und
dann ihre arbeit müssen wir irgendwo mit
um ladung mit dem springer und akkordeon
verlust muss einer mauer dann kann man
es wieder und die spanier weil sie sich
dann konzentrieren kindern oder
abschießen können am stück die werte oft
länger und die werden teilweise ein
wenig ruhiger
das heißt da ist das schießsport auch
gut dass man sich wirklich gezielt
konzentrieren kann und auch wenn das
vielleicht generell nicht liegt dass man
dann trotzdem diese phasen gut nutzt war
das dann nicht auch manchmal zu fahrzeug
jetzt mal am schießstand stehen am
gleichen platz stehen und den wir auf
die gleiche distanz oder durch die
verschiedenen distanzen dann auch zu
schießen als kind sucht man da nicht
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr
abwechslung das den aspekt wenn ich
nämlich auch spannend also mir war nie
fad und gestand also das war nicht der
typ der irgendetwas zu essen und müssen
oder der im springen hat mir ist
überhaupt gar nicht also wie war es
nicht für andres vielleicht partie war
sonst fußballspielen unter den
vereinsamten an vereinsamt und mit dem
laufen zum toben
da ist vielleicht ein bisschen fahrt
aber mir war das nicht fad
was war für dich dann
als zu sehen dass es funktioniert ich
kann das gut ich habe anscheinend ein
talent was war da bereits dass du dann
sagst ich mache daraus meine sportart
ich nehme mal an in dem alter gibt es
auch ganz viele andere sportangebote die
man als junges mädchen auch wahrnehmen
kann
aber warum hast du dich dann dazu
entschlossen ich möchte jetzt schießen
und bleibe auch dann schießen
es war irgendwie irgendwie ob man
relativ leicht rückläufig war nie der
läuft fordern was dieser bin
interessiert oder sonst irgendwas ist
das war einfach nicht mehr
und dadurch dass der papa mein trainer
war und immer noch ist
trotz diesen einfach so ergeben und da
bin ich einfach dabei blind ist es war
einfach mit ihm
aber man muss das schießen nicht nur das
schießen trainieren die anderen aspekte
gerne auch noch dazu wie kann man sich
denn dass das training in spitzen
erschießen vorstellen ja es ist fürs
training dabei und inzwischen
körperliche fitness braucht markt zu
meinem beruf und geradezu also jetzt
kehrt laufen gehen zum himmel dazu haben
wir sind immer so gern tour war es hilft
auch mal einfach mehr körper stabilität
und macht krafttraining und schaue
einfach dass man dort fit ist damit
wollen wir jetzt ewig weiter heißt noch
als eine korea zum beispiel dass man
nicht fünf komplett fertig ist wo man
dann schon entwicklung steht und dass
man einfach eine klimatische sachen
besser jetzt dass hitzfeld das klavier
das man körperlich gut drauf ist dass
man diese besser wegsteckt dass man muss
schon schauen dass die capri verfassung
gut ist das heißt man hat auch einen
seite die fitness die ausdauer aber auch
das spezifische das schießen und da aber
auch verschiedene
waffen ich hab da ein bisschen
hineingeschaut ja natürlich überhaupt
nichts verstanden ja auch überhaupt
nichts gemerkt
du bist sportschützin nämlich in der
luftpistole und in der sportpistole habe
ich das jetzt jemand erklären was es mit
diesen waffen auf sich hat also die
luftpistole diesmal auf zehn meter die
oder kartuschen drohten mit pressluft
führt die halt pressluftflaschen hat 200
bar traf und weil es ist einfach ein
luftdruck diesen an sich einige vorhaben
vom großvater vielleicht der luftdruck
werde irgend sowas und die sportpistole
kleinkaliber hoffen diesmal auf 25 meter
das kaliber ist 220 long rifle und
beschissen die biathleten chancen genau
das gleiche kaliber in manchester bis
dahin kann man auch sagen die
luftpistole ist nicht so gefährlich wie
die sportpistole reise beides gefährlich
und deswegen sollte man auch im handling
immer gut geschult und vorsichtig sein
ist es immer noch so dass jetzt der
luftpistole ist klar calwer oder no was
größer ist immer offen und ehrlich bist
du ja kürzlich bringt die fläche jetzt
hat gesagt 'wer ist dort wie und markus
schwer verletzten mann erzählen was
passiert
darum ist es immer das wichtigste am
schärfsten sicherheitsvorschriften
einzuhalten darauf dass er ihm
ausgerichtet und ziel und das man
ohnehin umspült dass das bringt man die
kleinsten schon bei der stimme schon
kann man dass die das handling machen
sind auf einmal um drei meter offen und
irgendwas passiert nun das war das der
supergau überhaupt
das heißt da wird auch von klein auf
geschaut dass alle die zum schießen
kommen in diesen dingen geschult sind
unbedingt es ist auch kein gefasst
hätten überlebensnotwendig er jetzt
wirkt es so als wärst du auch in den
waffen eine expertin muss man sich
zwangsweise wenn man sportschützen ist
auch mit den waffen auskennen gab es
dazu dass man die die waffen kennt
versteht auch wahrscheinlich die
funktionsweisen
gut versteht damit man die waffe gut im
wettkampf nutzen kann oder kann man auch
als nicht trafen experte ein guter
schütze sein ihr beides wird die songs
also sich auf einer quake live search
uhr wissen wir mehr als 100 buden und
dann wieder zum ball weil mappus nach
und die es gar nicht so wenig wo man
fisch ist also diese immer in ordnung
sei die luft bestehen dies liegt jetzt
sind wirklich wo man sie da ungefähr
wissen wie es funktioniert
um dann für service geht man zur firma
und die da stand dichtungsringe oder
sicher suchen einfach aus die mit der
zeit vielleicht ein bisschen spröde
werden oder je nachdem auf
abnutzungserscheinungen home & johnson
ja wie sie funktioniert dass dies lernt
mehr biss also im handling und natürlich
beim militär dynamit mit einstellung
wäre damit einer pistole
da lernst es noch viel mehr und hat sich
als seine vorteile
das heißt da gibt es dann auch
parallelen wo man eher gegenseitig
lernen kann der sportschütze sein und
beim bundesheer sein was
auseinandernehmen reinigen servicieren
als all die dinge die man als soldaten
oder als soldat auch kann hat dich das
ganze waffen thema fasziniert als junges
mädchen oder war dass er das was dich
jetzt nicht so unbedingt so stark
begeistert hat für mich war diese ganz
normal
dadurch dass der partner server schütze
gewesen ist jetzt sagen mir damit
aufgewachsen und da die bis dahin koffer
damals neue momentum gestanden sein weil
es für uns nichts aufregendes für uns
war jetzt einfach was normal ist
natürlich ein quiz das ist gefährlich
mit der von diesen treffer aber ich weiß
nicht so mein gott ich sage ja waffen
und um mein gott wie furchtbar ist
überhaupt nicht also wie viele waffen
hast du in deinem besitzt aber wir haben
jetzt also ich hab drei knackten
überworfen und luft bis dahin fünfziger
luft bestehen und dann mal die luft bis
zu 150 meter bist du also ist einiges
song kann man hätte
dh da fühlt sich dann auch
der schrank oder die waffen sicher
verstaut sind sind das auch der
wettkampf schaffen also mit denen musst
du dann auch im wettkampf schießen oder
ist das genormt und man bekommt vom
veranstalter oder vom verband genannte
waffen und jeder die gleichen waffen
oder hat jeder wirklich seiner eigenen
individuellen waffen na ja da hat seine
eigenen waffen also erstmal die klage
überworfen minister hat man meistens
zwei wochen mit brauner gebrechen ist
und im weg auf einer kommode waffen
tauschen
maria die passende munition dazu wir
haben jetzt ja spieler vor eineinhalb
wochen munition getestet dass man genau
die richtige munition zu richtigen
worten dazu haben das tor nicht gegeben
ist dass da irgendwas nicht passte
also das ist schon jeder sein eigenes
militär ist wieder auch schon nicht so
ein hehres meisterschaft vor noch dazu
eine eigene stimme mit die munition
kriege heute vom vorstädter dass jeder
die gleiche munition hat das heißt auch
da gibt es dann die unterschiede im
gegen das organisierte sport und ihre
neben im militär jetzt wasser dann
relativ früh erfolgreich ich hab hier
em-silber 2002 stehen weltcup gold 2017
european games rekord 2009/10 und eben
für tokio 20 20 25 21 für die
luftpistole qualifiziert das heißt der
sportliche erfolg hat sich relativ rasch
eingestellt wie war das für dich dass du
dann auch gesehen hast du geh ich kann
auf internationaler ebene und bühne
erfolgreich sein dass auch eine kurze
unterbrechung angesprochen war das würde
ich auch der reiz dass du sagst ich kann
da erfolgreich sein ich möchte das
machen ja es ist natürlich lässig wieder
voll dabei
es gibt es ein besseres dass wir normal
sport daraus machte marco da wirklich
mitmischen und 2002 vize europameisterin
gewesen bin bei der junioren das war
schon was ganz besonderes weil das war
gar nicht zu erwarten und donner vor mir
waren bin also erst 1 finale eingezogen
damals war die das finale in 38 und
unterstützt am treppchen
und noch ein weltcup gut das war der
hammer weil er war früher im
auslandseinsatz und die dem a-kader
gerechnet eigentlich und dass das ist
schon was ganz was besonderes
wo warst du da im ausland über einbußen
hin was hast du da in bosnien meistens
ansatz alles machen müssen bald
großvater von bataillons komponenten und
da kommen wir auch zu deinem jetzigen
job ist nämlich nicht nur als sportler
in erfolgreich sondern du bist beim
bundesheer und zweier kroatien kaserne
in sankt johann im pongau und bist eben
nicht als leistungssportler in einem
herr sportzentrum sondern eben einer
normalen einheit erzählt einmal wie es
dazu gekommen ist und was da genau
machst so mit ende zwanzig worden so die
überlegung okay weil ich vorher von 24
bis ungefähr 26
meine chancen aber meine motivation
komplett für und dann wieder opfern
gemacht weil er ist gleich wieder recht
gegangen
ok jetzt jetzt möchte in die weltspitze
werk wie man das machen
in der privatwirtschaft ist einfach da
noch mal was heißt jetzt probiert aber
das hat nicht funktioniert
und dann ist er aufgewachsen ist ein
schwerpunkt sport dort beim bundesheer
koma leistungssportlern zweite funktion
sei und ok just got back war beim
bundesheer ich im jänner 2012
beeindruckt mit einer 20 schon sehr spät
eigentlich hat dann die grundausbildung
gemacht also mit mitte 2014 war
unteroffizier mit ende 2010 war fertige
meiner stopps und offizielles ausbildung
und damir fras auf die qualifikation für
die olympischen spiele konzentrieren
china und seit april 2009 10 mit uns in
einer kaserne im ersatzteillager von der
werkstatt stationiert sozusagen und ja
im song für mich funktioniert die super
kurs ich habe die unterstützung von
bataillons komponenten über
kompaniekommandanten über meine
kameraden in der kasse
und wie muss hier kurze die sowjets das
sportliche so funktioniert und
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch viele
synergien die sich da gut nutzen lassen
aber wie kann man sich dann so einen
tagesablauf vorstellen dadurch das leben
nicht als leistungssportlerin im in den
heißt sozusagen bist wie lässt sich dann
deine tägliche arbeit die dort
verrichtet und und auch aufgaben hast
mit dem sport an vereinen wie
funktioniert das ja ich bin ganz normal
im dienst in der kaserne sie mitreißt
gestandenes kontrolle und dienstschluss
ist 15.45 und dann ja meistens geht nach
vorn laufen und ab und zu hause die
grunddynamik
je nach einteilung und seinem
qualifizierten hausgemacht da sie in der
dienstherr chancen gekommen
sonst aber noch ja und jetzt holen die
dienstzeit klickt dass sie dort zwar
meiner wochen am nachmittag am
schießstand bin und natürlich heute am
freitag arno und wochenende je nachdem
was es wert ergibt
und dies war sie vom leistungssportlers
zwei funktionen nutzen kann ist es gibt
ein hehres kader also ein militärisches
team wo man im monat buchen
trainingskurs das treffen wenn sie
entweder in rif im sportzentrum oder im
burgenland und trainieren mit oracle
wochen diese banker intensivere
intensiveres training hitzer und ja und
mode zu haben heute vom schützenbund aus
andere trainingskurse dieser so
monatsweise meistens treffe druck stellt
das ganze know how und trainings
partnerschaften nutzen sowohl vom
sportverband als auch über das militär
was auch schon beim militär world games
dabei und hast doch da schon erfolge
gefeiert das heißt auch diesen aspekt
hast du in deiner karriere mit dabei
aber jetzt schauen wir mal nach tokio
ist ja immer das große ziel für dich
gewesen sich zu qualifizieren
du hast ja auch qualifiziert nämlich
mitten in der kompliziertesten zeit die
wir als welt gerade so durch leben wie
war das für dich als die quali
fest stand es war wahnsinnige
erleichterung weil 2019 also ich war
vorher bei die ganzen welt cups da war
jahrzehnte nicht qualifiziert und ich
sie weiter macht man sich natürlich
selber einen großen druck weil totilas
ist ja das große ziel überhaupt und dann
dort ein zehntel dort 13
da wäre blödsinn das gibt es eine von
kienbaum diese letzte chance der letzte
weg kommt daher da wo es passt es wird
und dann ja gott noch ein weg konnte war
fertig ich bin relativ für schnellere
schütze es waren viele noch nicht fertig
dann gehe vom stand weg kabine
inzwischen ergebnis 15 tagen nämlich
dass der wir wollen trotzdem ja es ist
aber dann so gewesen dass man immer
weiter viereck rutschten um mit den
einzug ins finale war dann fliegst den
quotenplatz ab und die erleichterung war
riesengroß also endlich heute ist sie
kommt aber das heißt auch dass das du
anscheinend stärker auch hast dann wenn
es wirklich die letzte chance ist auch
abzuliefern
ich kann das aus meinem sport aus dem
schulsport dass das einen eindruck ist
also man weiß man hat jetzt nur noch
diese eine möglichkeit um sich zu
qualifizieren oder ein limit zu bringen
oder um sein ziel zu erreichen
wie gehst du in diesen momenten damit um
vor allem beim schießen wurde ja enorm
ruhig bleiben muss dann den rahmen
konzentriert bleiben muss also ich
stelle mir das irrsinnig komplex vor
hast du dein besonderes talent oder hast
du dich da besonders dafür vorbereitet
also wie wie schaffst du in deinem kopf
aus in solchen momenten
mein kopf ist ein ziemliches chaos
meistens weil 2016 bei der letzten
chance da habe ich richtig versorgen in
dieser saison darf da war vorher einmal
relativ knapp darunter bei der letzten
möglichkeit wasser vor katastrophen und
natürlich spürt deshalb ist sein im
hinterkopf macht diesmal dass der vize
und ich versuche dann immer zu schauen
nicht so sehr auf das ergebnis sondern
das ja auch meine technik und licht und
wasser das man sieht wo
ein bisschen mehr bewegt da sie ja gar
die aktionisten crew und ja ich war
wahnsinnig gutes ergebnis ich muss mal
vors volk recht friedlich und das ist
das was zählt erfahrung kann ich dich
beruhigen
in ein paar jahren fragt aber keiner
mehr nach dem genauen ergebnisse
qualifikation das ist das was zählt
wie schaut denn deine zielsetzung aus
für die spieler selbst natürlich dass
sie erfolgreich stattfinden können
wie geht man als sportschützin in so
einen so wichtigen wettkampf den man
vielleicht so noch gar nicht erlebt hat
kann man da auch schon abschätzen wo sie
meine chancen ist das feld wird durch
gemischt hat die bande mieter vielleicht
auch die ausgangssituation geändert also
viel spiel schaut das für dich aus mit
der zielsetzung für tokio als erste ziel
ist meins finale dann gilt wieder als
von lobos noch und groß erster oder ob
da während ist sieht man von vista
finale war das ziel und die online wenn
alle schlafen hier zurück was man sich
in soziale medien also dieser fleißig am
trainieren
es gibt bei uns ich glaube 20 kindern
fuhren sei also da ist die dichte so
groß oder es geht um ein vorher auf an
dem tag das kombination vorhersagen
crepaz der ist immer gut und der wert
kurzzeitig moskau nizza ist heute schon
favoritensterben gegeben
bei der olympischen spiele ich glaube
das ist in jeder sportart also und ja
möglich ist es also ich hoffe das beste
und es ist was spannendes bei der
european games show kennengelernt wir
sowieso kraft und die sich schon ganz
spezielles also bei mir steht da
edelmetall im visier das ist natürlich
natürlich eine super headline das heißt
es hängt auch sehr viel für
tagesverfassung habt würdest du das so
sagen ihr wollt die erstversorgung hier
weil du musst nur märz luft bis zehn
jahren in minder stunden muss einfach
passen
du hast nicht an gott spart bis zum märz
weiter auf der alte aber in der luft bis
hin zum beispiel in der stunde und sony
pastoren aus
du kannst du nichts mehr noch bessern
oder und hier noch kaufen oder sowas
der monitor ich muss was das heißt
abrufen wenn es gebraucht wird wenn man
gefragt ich es wenn es notwendig ist
dass auf hat einen auslandseinsatz
gesagt ich kann ja auch da vorstellen
dass das eine ausnahmesituation ist wenn
man so einen auslandseinsatz erlebt hast
du da auch genau diese schweren mentalen
momente wo der druck so groß ist wo man
sich vielleicht normalerweise schwer tun
würde hast du da auch etwas mit genommen
davon ist es etwas davon profitiert hast
dass du seinen auslandseinsatz einmal
erleben konntest ich war es war einfach
zu meiner ausbildung hause auf der
zugfahrt nach ok macht ist und das kann
man sie mehr oder weniger komme es ist
ja so eine planen das einfach gepasst so
vom zeitlichen ja es war 2016 auf 2017
glückshormone die quali für 2016 schon
für olympia erst später ins ausland und
wolle sich offenbar geht so und das war
einfach einmal so sorgt oder größere
pause einfach noch teams vorher zwar
richtig vollgas investiert hast und das
okay aber die solche passt also wenn das
ein indiz ist dann sollten wir mehr
heraus sprach der herr stadler in einem
auslandseinsatz schicken dann kommen sie
zurück und gewinnen
die welt gab es das doch gesagt und
damit kommen wir auch schon langsam zum
schluss dass du immer noch von seinem
vater trainiert wird seine trainer
sportler beziehung ist immer sehr
komplex und sehr schwierig aber vor
allem wenn wenn sie eben zwischen vater
und tochter besteht
wie funktioniert das bei euch passt das
von vom typ einfach gut oder gibt es da
immer wieder auch schwierige momente wie
ist das genau in eurer trainer
sportlerin und vater tochter beziehung
es war sicher nicht immer leicht und
marion bock sind ist man würde
durchsetzen und bis an beide studien
also deutschland bäume god of war serie
dazu entschieden habe mir zwei alpha
pony jetzt an die weltspitze
seit dem sommer richtig gutes team waren
also ist passt super gut wir verstehen
uns gut
er kennt mich natürlich genau wo es
meine fehler
er sieht die sagen also dieser bis jetzt
ein corner so gut gesehen und komma
höfen und irgendwie eher mau aus lassen
wollen auf kurs gewesen bin wohl doch
irgendwas war und dieses und jenes oder
rock kombinieren was und ich möchte das
nicht missen aber uns vielleicht ab und
zu erklingt charakter im oktober hätte
die letzten zehn auf zwölf jahre
funktioniert dies richtig super dass das
ein sehr auf jeden fall
das zeigt sich auf jeden fall gibt es
dinge die wo du sagst das habe ich von
ihm gelernt das habe ich das hat mir nur
beibringen können hätte ich von einem
anderen trainer so nicht lernen können
einfach nicht aufgeben aber durchhalten
bis zum schluss dies merken bei den weg
kommt immer wieder
und jetzt haben wir nicht so läuft wie
immer du hast wegkommt schüsse und zum
gerechnet werde zum schluss und die
sollte man schon öfter kurven dass ich
dann vielleicht zum schluss als sie gute
serienchancen und doch nur bin also
einfach das durchhalten diese arbeiten
dran
genauso diszipliniert sei also das ist
glaube ich hoffe ich schon vorher
ich glaube das ist auch ein super
schlusswort das ist auch etwas was jeder
mitnehmen kann wohl jeder davon
profitieren denn genau dieses
durchhalten als an bleiben diszipliniert
sein abgerechnet wird zum schluss das
heißt oder nicht in der von einem
fehlschuss auch unterkriegen lassen und
das ja auch im leben auch so dass wir
uns von von einem falschen schritt dann
aus dem konzept bringen lassen anstatt
weiter zu gehen und zu schauen dass man
dran bleibt sein ziel verfolgt und du
bist der beweis dass es funktionieren
kann
herzlichen dank für deine einblicke in
seine karriere in seine gedankenwelt
schießen selbst und natürlich
das gute für tokio danke danke sehr
ja das war es von uns vom sport hobart
danke dass ihr mit dabei war
wir freuen uns natürlich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten mal wieder einschaltet bis
dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]